Varys: Though the Targaryens had forged the
Seven Kingdoms in fire and blood, they didn't
govern with them.
Until they did.
Maegor, First of His Name, defined counsel
as confirmation and disagreement as treason.
Three Grand Maesters tried to avert disaster.
Instead of taking their advice, Maegor took
their heads.
As a second son and exile, Maegor was never
meant to rule.
But no sooner did Maegor hear of his brother's
death that he flew Balerion to Dragonstone
and demanded the crown.
Only the Grand Maester dared object that the
throne should pass to his older brother's
firstborn son, Prince Aegon.
Maegor insisted that the Iron Throne should
go to the man with the strength to seize it,
and beheaded the Grand Maester.
Prince Aegon soon took him at his word.
He claimed his father's dragon, raised a host
of Westermen, and marched on King's Landing
while Maegor was in Oldtown.
Far from the capital, Maegor couldn't rally
an army to match Aegon's.
So he ordered his banners to swarm Aegon's
larger army from all sides, confusing the
young prince and slowing his advance.
Beneath the Gods Eye, Maegor's disparate forces
came together and attacked Aegon as Maegor
himself swooped down from the clouds.
For the first time since the Doom of Valyria,
dragon fought dragon in the sky.
But Aegon's dragon was no match for Balerion
the Dread, who was four times its size.
When Aegon fell to his death, his army broke
and fled.
For slaying his own nephew, Maegor forever
after became known as "The Cruel."
Though, of course, not to his face.
The next Grand Maester dared object to Maegor
taking a third wife when taking his second
wife had ruined his brother's reign because
Maegor's first wife was the niece of the High
Septon.
But Maegor beheaded the Grand Maester and
declared war on the Faith.
He set fire to the Riverlands, the Westerlands,
and the Reach in a campaign to root out disloyal
lords and sponsored a more pliant High Septon.
None of it worked.
Maegor may have returned to the capital with
two thousand skulls of the Faith Militant,
but most of them weren't soldiers.
They were simple folk who had sheltered the
outlaw septons or turned out in droves to
hear them denounce the wicked king.
The third Grand Maester dared to declare Maegor
the father of his own heir.
But when his second wife miscarried, and Maegor
saw the monstrous stillbirth, Maegor beheaded
the Grand Maester for his insolent adherence
to truth.
So he had no one to warn him when his third
wife, sensing an advantage, declared that
his second wife had been unfaithful, and produced
a list of potential fathers of the misshapen
child.
Not only did Maegor execute his second wife
and her father, his own Hand of the King,
but he also marched on her family's castle
and slaughtered everyone who bore a drop of
her family's blood.
But his third wife couldn't give him a child
either.
Desperate to cement his stolen throne with
an heir, Maegor took three wives at once,
known as the Black Brides because each were
women he'd widowed in his wars.
All three women grew full with child in time,
but each gave birth to the same twisted monstrosities
as his second wife.
One need not be a maester, much less a Grand
Maester, to deduce the common thread here.
Though Maegor stamped out the fires of rebellion,
his cruelty and fear only scattered more tinder
over the realm until even the smallest ember
could set the realm alight.
One day, the Faith Militant emerged from the
shadows, and the lords sent to quash it joined
it instead.
His Hand resigned and retired to his island
home.
Finally, House Baratheon declared for Maegor's
own nephew as the rightful king.
The Lannisters, Tyrells, and Arryns soon joined,
adding more than half the might of Westeros
to the prince and his two dragons.
Which became three when Maegor's niece and
involuntary Black Bride stole away from the
Red Keep with her dragon.
Her treason wasn't even the last.
Maegor's own lord admiral sailed the Royal
Fleet into his nephew's harbor.
But most fitting of all, when Maegor tried
to send ravens to call his banners, he found
that his fourth Grand Maester had learned
from his predecessors and fled.
Maegor spent one final night on the Iron Throne.
He was found in the morning with his wrists
slashed and one of the throne's blades jutting
from his throat.
Nobody knows if it was one of his queens or
Kingsguard or one of the thousands who wanted
him dead.
Or even Maegor himself, frustrated that his
body had failed his will.
Whoever the culprit, no doubt he died as all
tyrants do.
Believing that history would vindicate him.
It hasn't.
History may be written with fire and blood,
but histories aren't.
As any good advisor could have warned him.
The coin of Aerys, Second of His Name, had
landed on madness.
But half the coins of the Targaryens had landed
so.
Yet only Aerys would be known as the Mad King,
thanks, in no small part, to the Defiance
of Duskendale.
Duskendale was the greatest port on Blackwater
Bay until Aegon built King's Landing.
As the capital grew richer and more prosperous,
it sucked ships and gold away from Duskendale.
To halt its long decline, the Lord of Duskendale,
Ser Denys Darklyn, petitioned King Aerys for
a royal charter that would allow him to levy
his own port fees and taxes, which would obviously
be lower than in King's Landing.
The Hand of the King, Tywin Lannister, refused.
But knowing of the tension between the Hand
and its king, Ser Denys invited the king to
Duskendale to evaluate his petition himself
rather than deferring to his Hand.
When Tywin admonished the king to refuse,
as any sensible advisor would, a petulant
and bristling Aerys instead accepted, traveling
to Duskendale with a small retinue and only
one of his Kingsguard.
As soon as Aerys stepped within the city,
Ser Denys seized him, killing the Kingsguard
and the few others who dared to defend their
king.
Aerys was hauled to the dungeons to have his
beard pulled and have other petty cruelties
inflicted on his royal person.
Lord Tywin immediately raised an army and
marched on Duskendale, but Ser Denys threatened
to kill the king at the first signs of an
assault.
If Ser Denys hoped to force Tywin to offer
terms, he didn't know Lord Tywin, who refused
to even parley until Ser Denys released the
king and surrendered.
The royal army surrounded the city, and the
royal navy blockaded it.
Ser Denys had clearly not anticipated such
obstinacy.
Nor that the king's Hand would be in no rush
to save the maddening king, when, as Lord
Tywin himself pointed out, the realm had a
better option in the king's much more stable
son, Prince Rhaegar.
After six months, Lord Tywin's patience was
at an end.
Or, at least, none could claim he acted recklessly
if he now stormed the city, and Ser Denys
killed the king.
But the dutiful and honorable Ser Barristan
the Bold volunteered to infiltrate the city
and rescue his king single-handedly, as befit
his Kingsguard oath.
Tywin couldn't refuse such valor publicly
and so begrudged Ser Barristan one night.
Then he would storm the city and put every
man, woman, and child to the sword.
With only his hands, Ser Barristan climbed
the city walls in the dark of night and snuck
through the city disguised as a beggar, evading
patrols and suspicious townspeople.
When he reached the walls of the city keep,
the Dun Fort, he scaled those by hand as well,
even dispatching the wall guard before he
could sound an alarm.
With incredible bravery and luck, Ser Barristan
made his way to the dungeons and freed his
king.
Then Ser Barristan's luck ran out.
A cry went up through the castle.
Someone had discovered the king was gone.
With horns and trumpets blaring an alarm,
Ser Barristan cut their way to the stables,
avenging his slain Kingsguard brother but
taking an arrow to his chest.
Slipping through the castle gate just as it
closed, the wounded Ser Barristan and Aerys
rode through the roused town, racing for the
city walls and, beyond it, the safety of the
royal army.
Lord Tywin's archers raced forward to clear
the walls of defenders, and Ser Barristan
the Bold earned immortality by delivering
King Aerys to the waiting, if not welcoming,
arms of his Hand.
Without his hostage, Ser Denys surrendered
and begged mercy from the same king he'd imprisoned.
Most men would have had none.
Aerys had less.
He commanded Ser Denys be executed along with
man, woman, or child who bore his family name
and anyone who once had.
As for Ser Denys's foreign wife, who had urged
his defiance, Aerys commanded that her tongue
and womanly parts be torn out, and she be
burned alive.
It was his first time passing such a sentence.
It must have given him a taste for it.
For the king rescued from Duskendale was not
the same king who'd entered it.
Many men would crack after six months in a
dark cell, being mocked, prodded, and tweaked.
Aerys had arrived cracked.
Now he was shattered.
For years, he would refuse to leave the Red
Keep.
Encouraged no doubt by his worried advisors,
since he also refused to allow any blades
near his person, even to shave his beard,
cut his hair, and trim his nails.
He began to see enemies in every shadow, who
vanished only when the fires burned.